tell us about a little bit about the
inspiration for your latest film which
is extraterrestrial ah british comedies
that that solid truth yeah I'm am I you
spend i hope the last decade being
amazed by the series by ricky gervais am
Steve Coogan for example I love a lot of
different generous in comedy but I
wanted to make I wanted to make a comedy
following this edition of uncomfortable
comedies instead of laughing all the
time your feel the anger all the time
and I wanted to give the movie a
background of sci-fi background because
I love sci-fi is my favorite generate
how much an impact do things like comics
and you love of them have on the kind of
films that you make um it's weird
because I didn't have a cinephile
childhood I was into coming boo since I
was a void because when you are rested
in atomic like mine in Spain making
movies is something so far for you so I
didn't throw myself as a filmmaker so I
bite a lot of comments at the time and I
was I felt I was going to be a comic
book writer but the real thing is that
we don't have a comic book market in
Spain a strong one so for me this is
sounds crazy ballot if was easier to
become a filmmaker than I can be book
writer what are you working on at the
moment I'm supposed to shoot a movie
this year that is called windows which
is going to be a thriller in the key of
my first film in the guild of ten crimes
it's not going to it's not it's not
going to involve 1010 travel again but
it's gonna be similar in many ways is
this it has a gain an intricate plot a
lot of twists and also prices and and
after all and after this movie I'm going
to make the adaptation of of supergroups
one of the one of the mark millar
franchise
we've been working hard in the screen
script there's something will work
together it is the first time a mark is
directly involved in a in a screen
script so I tried to put I tried to give
him my experience IAM blood in feature
films and he added his magic in dialogue
in character chemistry and what can we
expect from that tell us in terms of the
style what it will look like and maybe
casting as well I prefer much to talk
about the cassia because I've been too
shy about that because there's a lot of
citing names in the on the other page I
want to make a movie that is classic and
clean and meet them but at the same time
is raw and violent and comical
surprising at the end of the day it's
like a childhood dream that you working
on something like this given your love
of comic books yeah and they
specifically my love with Mark Miller
because i've been i've been a fan of his
work since they started polishing his
his comics in in spain in the 90s so i
was a close friend of him so at this
moment if i feel myself as the most
fortunate finally in the world because
i'm working with mmm and I all the time
pretending we are equal but it's not
it's not it's not the case yeah I it's
been lovely to speak to you and lots of
luck with both your projects you got on
the go at the moment and we look forward
to seeing them okay great
you